for as long as I can remember I've had a
fascination with
racing and I'm going to share a story
that barely seems
believable Jensen Buton crosses the line
takes the checkered flag how do you feel
it's pretty
amazing only one team in their debut
race in the history of the sport have
been able to get pulos and then go on to
win this is the story of Brun GP why did
people say that you were the one Formula
1 team I gave a pound to the Honda
executive allow us to buy the team to
get the team alive this is the only
option we've got on the table it's this
or the team gets shut
down can you do
this yes best way to become unpopular
very quickly is to start winning we're a
team that's come from nowhere no one
expected us to be here they went too far
there was something against the roof
this was the star
of the war this team that everybody just
wanted to survive is killing us I'm
going to win the championship the knes
were around and they were after us you
either push to the Limit or you're
nothing we push to the Limit people
believe in him because he looks innocent
it really behind the scenes smiling
assassin I think you're all smiling
assassins it was a really scary time
this is about survival Formula One once
it gets into your
blood it'll never let go
do you feel like Ross brwn was the
luckiest guy in the world or do you
think he was really
[Music]
clever